alright Michael Moore is now making
disaster movies his new one in eighth
place flop making only three million
total
it sank faster than the SS Poseidon does
this flop matter not to the media who
think American audiences don't see
Moore's films because we're all rubes
meanwhile the coastal elites use more
screens as a virtue signal Yoo Lian tell
friends you saw it the French say the
same thing so the license Morse films
are like vitamin supplements most offer
zero benefits but you still say nice
things about him but to his credit
Moore's movies are overtly political
unlike the rest of Hollywood's dreck
where producers inject politics as a way
to get crummy stuff made the script
sucks but on page 7 there's that part
about climate change at least more
where's his politics on his sleeve
God knows there's plenty of room now I'm
sure the media expected the film to open
big a rejection to trump and you it
didn't and it wasn't the lessons
ideology as entertainment is as loony as
a colonoscopy for recreation plus
America doesn't need a lecture from a
rich dude about how bad things are
especially when things are good we know
a lie when we see it our country's
metrics look great which turns more
cinema into a fairy tale for wounded
liberals yet as usual win more flops the
media ignores it if the movie was number
one you you can bet he'd be everywhere
there's that old saying about the media
you don't report on planes that don't
crash but you also don't report on your
favorite beliefs that do no judge we
just want to escape who goes to movies
for political like what would you go to
see a political movie right or left I'm
dying to go to a movie want a pizza
movies
I don't couldn't agree on a movie all
right we'll pick a movie no I'll pick a
movie both no I'll pick a movie Ben Hur
no you're going in the opposite
direction
she says she's with it yeah Kennedy what
do you want to see Oh what do I want to
see I love Marvel movies you know what
you can movie you know what you'd love
the new Nicolas Cage one Mandy Manny
Mania McMahon it was called Mandy that's
right oh it's fantastic nobody I heard
his characters unreal like yeah yeah but
it took funny because we're talking
about this we're not talking about it's
not entertainment it's not how people
consume that kind of information
everyone has giant Costco TVs now
everyone has a 50 inch plasma TV or
flat-screen whatever and so now you
you're on Netflix and Hulu and Amazon
Prime and soon Fox Nation and nice to
watch this incredible content and you go
to movies for total wipe ISM that's when
you've got a great point because in fact
Michael Moore had some hit movies that
were about news but now I think news is
so on the present people are sick I
think people want so the big week the
big movie in my family this weekend was
the house with a clock in the wall yeah
oh yeah I didn't go but the everybody
went except me because I work they liked
it they loved it but the little guys got
a little scared but I'm telling you
that's where people went they didn't go
to Michael Moore but I think it's
because boy the news is kind of rough
right well you know you need escape in
Fahrenheit 9/11 and Fahrenheit 11 9 the
first movie was based on a conspiracy
theory and audiences loves that remember
the Saudi connection to the Bush family
Dick Cheney's war profiteers the WMD
scandal the CIA they love that stuff and
it gave meaning to the anti-war left at
the time and the critics loved it
because it was fresh now if you want
that there's no conspiracy with Donald
Trump it's all out in the open there's
nothing going on behind the scenes of
anything people are conspiring again
Tim and if you want anti-trump
propaganda you watch CNN or you watch
MSNBC you know what's interesting though
and and Michael Moore was one of the few
people who called the election ahead
right but there were very very few so
many people all the pollsters were off
and he was the one person on the left
who said I know these people I know
these people in Michigan and in the Rust
Belt and they are so disenfranchised and
identity politics doesn't ring true with
them what he is saying resonates and he
could easily win at least this part of
the country and he was absolutely right
so he makes a better analyst than he
does properly I think he said identity
pot white identity politics was
resonating because they thought somebody
else was being was benefiting not them I
think that's what it is
and Jesse by the way I just I just to me
when you look at Michael Moore it seems
to me Michael Moore was hitting
something that was very real before and
you could say oh no conspiracy this time
I tell that to the Russians what was the
conspiracy its Russians book material
its Russia's behind the flop the
Russians there but I think they're in
the wall they're in that yes all right
shall we move on